Villar is the perfect technology for
making gaming more accessible and
Ubisoft Montreal's fun house team built
a game that just about everyone is going
to know how to play the minute they put
on their headsets so here to take us
into the world of Eagle flight
please welcome creative director Shahu
toe along with two huge fans of the game
Palmer Luckey inventor and founder of
oculus and Jason Holtman head of
publishing at oculus VR
I am very excited to show you begin
today and even more excited to have you
guys to play with us thanks for having
us we're really cute fans of Eagle
flight that's very very intuitive game
and the flight mechanic is super
innovative and it gives you that real
freedom of flying in VR but most of all
it's just super fun and by super fun I
mean I can beat Palmer almost every time
I play ok that's not true we've been
playing this game for months at oculus
and we've been getting pretty good at it
and this is a really good chance for us
to come and show everybody that we can
beat you guys at your own game let's go
hello everyone my name is Carsten Myhill
and I'm going to talk you through for
the first time ever at e3 a live PvP
demo in VR it's called capture the prey
and two teams of three will battle it
out in the skies over Paris over here we
have the blue team resplendent in their
Hawaiian shirts led by Palmer Luckey
Olivier and Vicki and the red team led
by Jason Hawkman with his two wingmen
Andre and Charlie the rules are simple
it's a catch of the flag game and we
will play best of three so if we're
ready to go let's fly
so we can see the first location of the
prey right there at the foot of the
Eiffel Tower and they have to take it to
the nest to score a point it's a bit
like football they have to work as a
team
taking the object and bringing it to a
goal all right maybe not the greatest
analogy in the world but you get the
idea
teamwork is key to succeeding in this
game Paris has been reclaimed by NATO we
can see the song dem are overrun now
with beautiful trees and undergrowth and
nature and the scape animals from the
zoo
like those giraffes over there Olivier
has the rabbit and is making his way
over to the nest right now he's trying
to stay lone using shortcuts weaving in
and out of the trees taking little
alleyways and tunnels where ever he can
try to stay out of sight of his
opponents who are trying it's trying to
tip
oh and it's big nipple and rape and the
rabbit is down Charlie's got it so the
red team in possession killed by Vicki
who's going to pick it up
they're not far from the nest now and
it's Olivier for the blue team yeah
there's a nest a blue gonna score first
yes they are one meal to the blue team
okay remember it's best of three so the
red team needs a score stay in the
content key with the amazing steal of
their blue right into the line of sight
of Andre who took it from her into the
tunnels utilizing gusts of winds of
thermals to get a speed boost Andre
looks like he's gonna hit him a free run
at the moment
someone shooting everybody
Andre stay hello Jason Bing wingman
backing him up over to the panthéon
there oh great killed by Jason
but andre has it for the red team don't
about five each other that's not gonna
work okay the final location is right
there at the top of the Eiffel Tower
don't ask me how the rabbit got up there
it's an extremely exposed position we'll
see them shooting at each other as they
head up to try and get that final rabbit
to win the game yeah Parma with a kill
could work and Andres down great shot
Nikki taking him out there Vicki in this
slide the Eiffel Tower
utilizing the thermals
get the [ __ ] stone
Vicky with the steel
okay we're fixin to get to that finalist
no fall to go down
I'll take a minute for the red team and
the blue team we were still right here
to win the game order regime
he's gonna stop now
for those of you here you can come to
the Ubisoft booth and the oculus boom to
try out yourselves so we've got to come
and see you down there
thanks very much have a great you three